this week a bipartisan group of
lawmakers brought forward a new
908 billion dollar stimulus proposal
to try and revive failed coronavirus aid
talks in washington
the plan has not entirely been finalized
and could still change
but the idea is to include 300 weekly
enhanced federal unemployment benefits
for four more months
as well as give 160 billion dollars in
state and local aid
and liability protections for businesses
in the short term
as for another round of stimulus checks
that is looking unlikely
because they'd make the bill so much
more expensive the agreement would also
provide another 288 billion for small
businesses
including the paycheck protection
program 45 billion for transportation
25 billion for rental assistance and 35
billion for health care providers
nancy pelosi and chuck schumer just came
out and said you know we think that
that bipartisan 900 billion dollar plan
is actually a good place to start
and that's a major shift from what what
they had been saying up till now
it still will need mcconnell's buy-in
and that's a question mark and it also
will still need the president's buy-in
if it's going to pass before the end of
the year and that's a question mark
so too soon to tell but there has been
movement
according to mitt romney who is part of
the group drafting the plan
348 billion dollars of the package is
new money
the remaining 560 billion would be drawn
from unspent money from the cares act
and emergency federal reserve lending
programs during a senate banking
committee hearing this week
treasury secretary steven mnuchin cited
positive economic data
as evidence that a smaller stimulus bill
would be more appropriate
he also noted mitch mcconnell president
trump
white house chief of staff mark meadows
and house minority leader kevin mccarthy
also support more targeted legislation
mcconnell introduced a new targeted
stimulus plan of his own this week
but it's likely to draw criticism from
democrats who say it's too small
biden this week also came out talking
about stimulus and
he has been a proponent of a bigger bill
all along you know he supports
he said he has supported that 3.4
trillion
heroes act from the house but this week
he said you know he wants to see
something immediate but he said that's
just a starting point so that kind of
opens the door
to more legislation after he takes
office and on top of all this pressure
to get something done for americans
hurting from the pandemic
congress also has to deal with the
federal budget before a december 11th
government shutdown deadline
it's possible for additional coronavirus
relief to be bundled with the spending
bill
but only if lawmakers can agree in time